thank you Thank You Shannon hi I'm Elena
I'm an engineering manager on Google
Play I lead app distribution and
developer console platform team I'm here
to talk to you about how you can launch
smart on Google Play so Ellie did a
great overview of how you can develop
smart and do do well while you're
developing I'm here to also tell you a
little bit about what you do when you
come to - - launching on Google Play
more specifically I want to talk about
rapid iteration and how you can iterate
your app to higher quality into a better
market fit using some of the tools that
we provide in Google Play Developer
console
I'm also going to talk about how you can
analyze your app how you can experiment
with various things both about your app
and about your store store listing how
you can optimize number of different
things how you can localize go globally
and in general just going to improve
performance of your app and Google Play
Store we're also going to talk a little
bit about how you can really listen and
hear what users are telling you about
your app and then how you can interact
with them by by addressing their
feedback and then we're very briefly
gonna touch on how you can monitor how
you can do all this on the go and
especially how we can monitor the state
- your app on the go so let's start with
launching and iterating I wanted to
start with this quote we got from a
Michael reader the SVP of business
development at sgn so they share this
feedback with us why they launched
genies and gems on Android first
basically they told us that because they
can iterate very fast to Google play
because the publishing delays are so
laws are very low and the publishing is
very quick they were they were able to
kind of achieve very significant
business outcomes there is more of a
quote SG ins are very
users of beta testing of store listing
experiments and number of different
iteration tools and experimentation
tools that I'll keep referring to in
this talk but kind of the interesting
thing was also the day took a number of
findings from kind of their their their
insights from experimenting using our
tools and then we're also able to apply
them to other platforms which is a very
efficient way of doing business okay so
as I as I go through this talk I will be
referring to various different stages of
launching and I suspect many of you have
done this before you you have went
through these steps the first one would
be beta testing so that's when you have
kind of the core flow of your app the
core idea of what you want to do but
you're still not ready to go very widely
with it you want to you know try it out
with a few friends family maybe and
please your company you know kind of
some sort of narrow narrow audience the
second step would be soft launching so
this is when you actually want to expose
you what you want users do to you know
get their hands on your abdomen them to
try a few things you want them to
actually try to use it you can measure
some KPIs like our abusers returning to
your Europe how is our daily active
users how does retention look how are
kind of this basic KPI is looking about
your app at some point you will you know
can window all of those numbers look
really good when users are you know
spending money or spending time within
your app you will want to launch so kind
if we will also talk about what are the
tools that are helpful at that point and
then we also talk about what happens
after that after the initial launch you
still put a keep going in the app you
want to keep adding new features you
want to keep kind of making it better
and that basically kicks off this whole
cycle again of kind of when you are
considering your features that you want
to beat the tests that you want a soft
launch and eventually launch and so on
okay I'll start with beta testing first
more than 60% of the top thousand apps
on Google Play are running a beta test
right now
this has been a very very popular tool
we have heard really great feedback from
from developers about it I there is you
can run as I mentioned close beta test
with a very limited limited audience you
can run open beta test with a bunch
wider audience where you can get
more feedback I will not go into details
about how each one of these work what
are the pinnacle of different different
things about it what are the things that
are they're the same I'm I will be doing
office hours later here today and I'll
be here throughout the day so if you
have any questions about that I'm more
than happy to answer however one thing
that I do want to talk about is some of
the improvements we've made to the beta
testing in the last couple of months one
of those was at i/o this year with
allowed users to start opting in to apps
with open betas from the Play Store
itself so users can now discover apps
with open beta programs and they can
opt-in directly from from the Play Store
this is proved to be you know that very
step that kind of removes the the churn
and of fusers joining joining your beta
test so the many apps have told us that
they've got 10x larger beta programs as
a consequence of making this change so
it's kind of it beta testing in that
sense becomes a very powerful soft
launch tool where you can actually get a
meaningful number of users using your
app while while it's still kind of in
development and you can actually get
relevant KPIs you can work on optimizing
those KPIs really kind of making them
better so at the point when you when you
launch fully your kind of really ready
which is exactly what we recommend we
recommend if you haven't tried this we
recommend you try running an open beta
and getting users feedback and kind of
really really trading and working on it
it does help you get to a higher quality
build it helps you get better product
market fit and it helps you find your
your fine-tune your KPIs can fold the
metrics that you care about about your
app or your game one more thing that we
launched recently is private feedback
from your beta testers again beta
testers can submit feedback directly
from the Play Store front however don't
worry no one else gets to see this it's
just for you you can see it in developer
console and this these reviews don't
affect your average rating so it's a
very safe environment for you to try out
different things it's okay if not
everything works it's better that you
find out about that during the beta test
then once you're launched to everyone in
product
and another recent addition to the beta
testing program is early access so this
is a new collection which we are now
showing to do two users in the Play
Store front which features interesting
apps and games that are still in
development but that are running an open
beta test users can find them discover
them there and then again this is kind
of another way that's bringing people
who are interested specially those users
who are early adopters who do want to
try new things who do want to you know
could yeah be the first ones to discover
an app and to use it they're the ones
you know kind of whoo-hoo-hoo you can
push feedback you can basically get by
being part of the early access program
if you do have an app coming out soon
please do reach out to us and you know
mention that you would like to be part
of the early access program we are
actively onboarding apps do it there are
a couple of I will not go into details
but the developers that have been part
of the early access program so far have
shared really really good feedback with
us they've told us that it really helps
them you know kind of yep it proved the
quality again kind of iterate try out a
lot of things in a very in a very nice
and quick way and just kind of a couple
of notes my favorite ski that was from
Reed field which is an online book club
which was a part of the first batch of
apps that were part of early access
program so they've told us that being
part of early access helped them
identify in your markets so can you
forward the different things their app
could be doing the to to to kind of
really be useful for more users they've
told us that they were able to identify
number of different bugs a number of
different feature requests that users
really want in addition to that they
were able to a/b test various different
things within their app too before they
launched ultimately to everyone and then
finally they were all able to build a
community of very passionate users these
early adopters or users who you you know
they are the promoters for your app
they're the community that can really
kind of create a lot of buzz about your
app so this is why this is another
benefit you could get from this and if
all this wasn't enough to convince you
the stuff launching is a really good
thing to try out there are a few more
things
sometimes we hear feedback from
developers who say that you know they
would rather keep it kind of close and
tight and then just do kind of a big big
bank launch keep in mind that you only
get one chance to make first impression
with your users obviously want to make
the looking the right first impression
and the other thing is if you if you try
out your app just with you know 10 or or
50 users before you actually launch it
your risk you know kind of those users
being your friends maybe not being
honest or kind of not not telling you
like a lot of data-driven stuff of like
how often they use your app how often
you don't kind of they're returning to
it and all that so definitely consider
something that's a little bit more
scaled before you actually launch openly
to everyone okay a couple of tips on how
to soft launch closed beta would be the
first thing to do you want to kind of
yep the smaller limited set of people
you want to test out the proof of
concept the core game mechanics of or
deep core app flows there are kind of
important to you basic user experience
obviously want to catch the the crudest
of crashes and you want to get some
open-ended feedback from your users as
the second stage consider a soft launch
that's still kind of a bit limited you
can you can do this limiting by either
choosing a subset of countries perhaps
the ones that are you know the tab fewer
users we hear very often that the
developers do soft launch in New Zealand
which is kind of a good approximation
for big markets like US or Europe but
it's still kind of smaller in the in the
in the size or you can limit based on
the number of devices or languages or
kind of any in any different ways at
that point you can already start to
track the metrics that you get so at
this point you can already start looking
at the actual data coming in and rather
than you know trusting people to write a
couple of lines of how they like your
app you can actually see it already
using it twice a day or they using it
for an hour a day that's kind of those
are very useful signals and then is the
final stages before you launch you want
to consider going open beta to all the
actual markets where you're looking to
talk to launch externally at this point
you should be able to get sufficient
data to really kind of make
sure that your token if you're a gamer
game economy is working or that you know
kind of users are using your app in a
way that you would like them to use
okay so let's slot in these two things
that we talked about into our app
lifecycle or our launch lifecycle so
beta testing and early access it's
important to keep in mind they're useful
all throughout of your lifecycle you
want to use them to soft launch you want
to use them as your launching for the
first time it's kind of to everyone and
then you want to keep using them after
that to keep iterating on all the you
know kind of new features that you're
building and to keep improving your app
okay let's talk a little bit about how
you can improve the quality of your app
early on Ellie has talked about firebase
test lab so I'm gonna keep building on
top of this I'm gonna talk a little bit
more about the pre-launch report
privilege report is powered by a
firebase test lab so all of the apks
that get uploaded to alpha and beta
channel in developer console
automatically get sent to to firebase
test lab and we run a number of monkey
tests on them we try out kind of testing
out various different things and then
kind of based on that we generate a
report which is shared with you within
an hour of you uploading those apks to
Google Play Developer console the first
thing that you want to check out in the
report are crashes we will run the tests
on you know kind of a couple of tens of
devices this is generally more than you
can this probably more than you can do
yourself while you're kind of developing
all the time so it's quite useful it's
you know automatic it's free so it just
kind of comes in as a very nice cheap
way to detect these crashes early in
particularly you know you don't want to
catch these crashes before they turn
into one-star reviews and you know can
everyone see the knows about them for
every crash report you will be able to
see stacktrace
you'll be able to see device metadata
and then some kind of other metadata
about the run and and and and so on the
other thing that part of the pre-launch
report are screenshots so this as we as
we do these monkey test on your apks we
take screenshots of kind of
all along the way and then we share
these screenshots with you in Google
Play Developer console
this comes in pretty handy to see how
your app looks on various different
device screen sizes or dpi eyes or kind
of anything's like that it also comes in
pretty handy as you can see in the
highlighted screenshot for testing out
we try testing out to a couple of
different languages and the for example
in this screenshot you can see that the
German translation SAR too long and they
make the UI kind of overflow a little
bit so you know again you want to catch
this before the app is actually launched
and then finally we also share security
alerts about the APK s that you just
uploaded
obviously I know no one here would you
know kind of upload security
vulnerability on purpose but it does
happen sometimes by mistake it also does
happen if you pull in a third-party SDK
for example ads or analytics library
these sometimes you know can come in
with security vulnerabilities so again
you you want to find out about this
sooner rather than later
and a quote we got from flink who who
were really happy with the pre-launch
report so far they're saying that it
helps them test on way more devices than
they could afford if they were to do it
manually okay and let's lock pre-launch
report again just like be the testing
and early access it's sort of useful all
throughout your your launch lifecycle
you want to try it early on it's never
you know it's never too early to start
getting this feedback you want to use it
as your launching and you want to use it
once your app is live
cool let's talk a little bit about
analyzing experimenting and and
optimizing the first tool that I want to
talk about this user acquisition report
user acquisition report is a conversion
funnel that shows you how many visitors
to your store listing you're getting how
many of those are turning into
installers and then how many of those
are actually buying something within
your app and eventually becoming a
repeat buyers you can also break down
this report based on the acquisition
source so whether this is organic
traffic that skill came kind of through
the Play Store or whether whether this
is paid traffic the scale
through through ads or something like
that as a very recently you can also
break down this report by country so you
can see how your convert whether for
example your localizations are not great
and you're not converting that well in
you know kind of Asia compared to Europe
and so on
and once you yeah once you once you have
this data obviously I want to optimize
you know kind of just just having the
data for for for its own sake it's not
very useful the tool that kind of fits
in really well with user acquisition
report and that will help you optimize
this kind of very top of the funnel this
kind of drop off between number of
visitors and installers are store
listing experiments this has been
another tool that has been very very
successful so far developers have told
told us that they really like it
precisely because is when you optimize
the top of your funnel you make the
whole funnel wider and basically it's
more likely that you know kind of more
users will eventually also turn to
buyers and to repeat buyers and and so
on more than 70% of our top developers
use policy experiment it's it's it's a
great number and you know kind of it's a
I don't think it's surprising given that
it's a you know kind of it's bringing
results it's bringing it's bringing you
better conversion rates and it's
bringing you more installers and that's
kind of precisely what you want the
other thing is obviously the tool is you
know free the only thing that you need
is a designer or a copywriter so someone
you know kind of who can actually work
with trying to optimize your store
listing and trying to kind of convert
more users for you I'm going to give you
a lot of examples examples about store
listing experiments I feel that's the
best way to show you how developers are
actually using and to give you ideas so
if you know kind of what what would
useful to try out and to test here there
are two to the I want to start with here
are Flair games who have run with a
single eye contest for their royal
revolt 2 they have managed to increase a
user acquisition rate by 30 percent
so this was pretty good like run once
test you know going to fin and be able
to do to increase number of installers
by that much
IRRI public lab is kind of a little bit
on the on the other side for there for
launch of age of Lords they have run a
drink of different experiments and they
have ranged from plus 5% to plus twenty
nine percent until have really kind of
overall improvements their acquisition
rate were also pretty high that was
really good
Expedia is another interesting example
they you know you would think Expedia is
a well-established brand at this point
is that you kind of experimenting with
their assets wouldn't be worth it that
turned out not to be the case they have
managed to get there is a global install
rate up by ten percent
by optimizing their assets so it's worth
thinking that if Expedia is a
well-established brand can do this then
apps that are very early in their
lifecycle can do even better you can if
you can go with bolder changes you can
try even more things and not going to
get even better results one of my
favorites spry Fox is alpha bear as you
can see they have a very unique visual
style and a very very interesting
creative you know kind of vision for
what they wanted to do and yet they were
able to kind of experiment with
different icon types icon is
particularly big for games kind of
experimenting with with different icon
types for games is a really big thing
they started with the one on the far
left and it turned out that one on the
far right is actually converting
converting eighteen percent better so
you know it's kind of worth ya
experimenting with with a few of these
different ones
instacart had a really great success
with the experimenting with their short
description so just by changing their
short description they managed to
increase their conversion rate by
fourteen percent and what we generally
found to work really well is short and
to the point short descriptions which
explain the value of your the value
proposition of your app in the shortest
kind of possible way they said this is
what we've seen kind of work
very well consistently and Angry Birds
went to town with it they kind of really
went on the on the store listing
experiments bandwagon and they were
testing for four Angry Birds pop
launched they were testing the icon over
and over and over again it keeps going
basically they were running test after
test after test and with each one they
were choosing a winner and then trying
out even more kind of variance I guess
there are designers we're having a lot
of fun with this until they ended up
with the one that was kind of in in
double-digit double-digit increase
comparing to where they started so it
just kind of it's it's it's worth not
just testing once it's worth keeping the
iterations going and just really keeping
the keeping this moving because you can
there there seems to always be some
games to be had in in this area and the
final one I promise this last example
this is mixing this one is interesting
because mix is a like a very big
Japanese developer but they were looking
to to go into u.s. they wanted to do to
bring their monster strike game into
into u.s. however they they had a
feeling that the local tastes of people
in the US would be different to local
taste of people in Japan so they wanted
to make sure that they really match the
that local take the taste is expressed
in the in the store listing so they
started iterating on the on the feature
graphic or on the video then went on to
to to iterate on the screenshots on the
description and and eventually on the
icon over the the scope of a couple of
months they have managed to increase
their conversion rate by 68 percent by
running kind of test after test in a
very scientific very methodical way very
persistent way so it's just kind of it's
two main takeaways from this would be a
you know kind of keep keep going at it
keep kind of making changes and keep
testing and the other one would be
yes users in different countries have
very different tastes to taste the very
different kind of local flavor so you
know confuse store listing in Asia will
probably end up looking much different
to your should end up looking much
different to your store listing in New
York
okay couple of best practices that's the
multiple languages this is exactly what
I what I was tell you just now so it's a
yeah kind of worth trying out different
things for four different languages and
as of earlier this year you can run
multiple tests in parallel in different
languages so this can now be very easy
and efficient it's rate you know keep at
it keep you know kind if it looks like
there is always kind of a next
improvement to be had focus on one thing
at a time so it's kind of if you're
don't do icon and description test at
the same time because it's going to be
hard to know what actually worked so
choose to optimize the icon first and
then optimize the screenshots or so on
try to come up with some sort of
hypothesis this is another thing that
we've heard this kind of do you feel
like your icon is too busy or do you
feel your colors are too pale or just
connect if you can try to come up with
some sort of hypothesis then you can you
know kind of possibly optimize anymore
in a better way than just randomly
trying out different text or graphics
give it some time it takes time to reach
the pistil significance with with these
results don't you know kind of we try to
do we pay a lot of tension to tell you
when we think the the the experiment is
done and ready but in general just
giving it more time is gonna be you know
kind of forced it will be more sure that
it's going to yield actual good results
and finally be bold yeah especially if
you're early in your startup's life you
know try out a lot of different things
it's kind of it's harmless and it's
cheap so it's worth playing around with
a lot of different visual identities
okay and the last thing related to
localizing earlier this year we've also
launched pricing templates pricing
templates allow you to manage the
pricing for your entire app and in a
product catalog in a kind of in a bulk
way in a very easy bulk way so if you
haven't switched the DEM yet many levers
have but if you haven't switched them
yet we definitely recommend them as a
very efficient bulk pricing management
tool however on top of that when we
added pricing templates we've also added
smart localized price rounding so for
example if you input your default price
and auto convert to two all the 70
markets to which Google Play Now sells
using the latest conversion rates
we will do the smart rounding so for
example you don't end up with 0.73 euros
price you end up with 0.99 or you don't
end up with 182 Japanese yen we would
round that to 200 japanese yen so these
kind of we came up with these smart
locally relevant pricing rounding rules
so we are just going to make sure you
refresh your prices do to pick those up
your pure store listing in your catalog
will look more professional to users in
those countries and it will also look
more relevant for their local culture
okay let's do let's slot couple of these
tools in our lifecycle as well
user acquisition tool user user position
reports or the experiments of pricing
templates all only valid once you fully
launch these are the tools that require
you to have a lot of data or like
certain amount of data before you can
kind of work with them so you can only
use them once you launch it once you
keep iterating on your app once once
it's fully launched ok let's talk a
little bit about about listening to what
your users are really telling you and
about interacting with with your users
we've touched very briefly on the
private feedback in the in the first
section beta testing but let's say now
you're launched you're out to kind of to
add to everyone and there is a lot of
feedback coming in what do you do with
all those feedback but before that let
me just refer to kind of two things that
may not be entirely obvious as you work
on your app quality especially this
quality is reflected through your
average rating score you will actually
also be increasing your revenue this may
not be entirely obvious but the feedback
we've heard from number of developers
and the recent one is from a game ville
is that by bringing their app from three
point three stars to 4.1 stars they've
also increased their revenue by 160
percent I mean this is pretty good stuff
right so it's worth trying out the other
thing that totally may not be obvious is
that by working on your quality through
improving the average rating you're
actually also working on your velocity
so aviary shared a very interesting
feedback with us recently that
what they started doing is they start
the stage rollout and then they start
getting a lot of feedback from users and
they analyze this feedback which allows
them to cut their release cycle to two
to three weeks which they weren't able
to do before or they're not able to do
on other platforms so just kind of by
really shifting your cycle your
development cycle to make kind of
addressing reviews a core part of it you
can also increase your velocity and ship
faster
in the past year we've done a lot of
improvements too you know because we
realized ratings reviews are really
important we've done a number of
improvements in the area make sure to
check them out in the Google Play
Developer console new user overhauled
user ratings section overhauled user
review section and a completely new
review analysis section that I'll come
back in a minute and I'll talk a little
bit more about it but it's definitely
worth kind of checking out all the other
improvements that are there another
thing that I'll come back to a little
bit later is the new mobile you know go
go play developer console mobile app
which we've launched but in this case I
just want to talk about it very briefly
in terms of how how it can help you
manage customer feedback and how it can
help with customer interaction into a
new mobile app obviously you can see the
latest reviews you can see the user
rating you can see various breakdowns
and all of that but more importantly you
can also interact with your users you
can reply to user reviews directly from
the from the app why that's important
here is because the customer interaction
has this very important time component
so it's kind of it's important to reply
to your user feedback in a timely
fashion and when you have you know kind
of developer console app in your pocket
this now becomes much easier you don't
have to go back to your desk and you're
not going to type it in properly there
the other thing that we've launched with
the app is the notifications so you can
you can get notified when users change
their review after your reply or when
they post one-star reviews or kind of
anything like that that you will really
like to react in in a quick way
and talking about responding to user
reviews this is starting to be really
big in the past year we had 92 percent
growth in the number of developer
replies this vastly this is actually
bigger than the the organic growth in
number of apps organic growth the number
of reviews that are being posted so
developers are really picking up this
practice and they're really starting to
to reply a lot so this is worse this is
something that's worth considering if
you it does lead to more to to hire
average average rating it does lead to
you know kind of users feeling more
appreciated so it's kind of users are
almost starting to to to to expect now
the developers the developers will reply
to their reviews okay so the other kind
of talking about reviews with a recently
launched review analysis section there
are a couple of a couple of different
things where we really work hard to help
you parse all this feedback and allies
all this feedback you get from
developers
one of those is highlights so we extract
all the relevant snippets and phrases
that users are mentioning in your app
and then we kind of yes select them for
you in both developer console we also
show these in the Play Store front so
it's kind of worth keeping an eye of
when kind of what we're showing in the
in the storefront and checking it out in
developer console as well the other
thing with launch recently our review
topics so again we do various machine
learning and natural language processing
to extract the topics that we think are
relevant and again the users are talking
about when they when they write reviews
for your app so for example if you are a
language learning app like the one here
we would extract all the various
languages that users or may be asking
for or mentioning if you're a car racing
game we might be talking about various
different things about cars or about
racing and so on on top of that you can
actually see how each one of those
topics what's the average rating of
reviews that mention the topic
what's the number of review
and then also what is the effect on the
rating that this topic has so this kind
of allow this basically tells you what
is the easy area to focus on if you want
to improve something so kind of here for
example we can immediately tell that the
fact that this language learning gap
doesn't have support for Klingon you
know kind of is causing like a lot of
negative reviews the other thing that
we've launched recently also part of
review analysis was benchmarks so we
identified eight characteristics that
every app has those eight are things
like design speed stability and so on
for each one of those eight again we
show you based on your user reviews what
what is the average rating like what is
the sentiment of users with regards to
this particular benchmark and then we we
also show you how your app compares on
this particular aspect to other similar
apps apps in the same category or apps
they're in the same monetization model
or something like that
and then we will show you if effect on
rating is like so is design a big plus
of your app or is speeds a big minus and
and so on and it finally kind of for one
interesting point about review analysis
we also analyzed the complete corpus of
all the ratings and reviews on Google
Play there's a lot of them one
interesting thing that we found out is
that majority or 50% of all one star
ratings mentioned or related to
stability in bugs and then 65% of all
five star ratings are related to speed
design or usability so it's kind of you
know important keeping in mind what is
the thing that's actually driving the
rating up and what is the thing that's
actually driving the rating down and
what are the things that your users are
really irritated with in what what are
the things that users really happy about
a very brief mention for also our new
reviews API if you want automated way to
fetch your reviews from Google Play and
to reply to them we now have an API for
that it's only a couple of lines of code
integrate with it super easy however if
you would rather not to do that
there is also kind of out-of-the-box
integration with the some popular
customer relationship management tools
like Zen decks and convert social so can
if you if you would like more integrated
approach to managing your your customer
feedback or we have a way to do that as
well
okay let's slot in these two tools as
well reduce analysis a review API
they're very useful not in this first
stages you're launching your app for the
first time but they become absolutely
critical at the point when your app is
live and you're receiving all the
feedback from users and you want to keep
working on it and keep improving your
app okay the last thing monitoring your
app and go as I mentioned we launched
the play console app at Iowa's year and
then in the you know doing ending the
best kind of way of doing what we're
preaching here we've also done a fast
follower release couple of weeks later
this fast follower obviously included
number of stability fixes but it also
included the number of new features that
you guys told us would be really good to
have in the app it included review
notifications being able to manage store
listing experiments directly from the
app being able to increase the stage
rollout or to hold a bad staged rollout
of your app if you still haven't tried
the app please do send us feedback we're
reading it we're actually reading it
where we're kind of trying really hard
to address it and where we want to keep
adding new features due to play console
app and one more mention of another app
that we have which is playbook for
developers for you guys this is the
perfect place to keep getting insights
about what's new in Google Play to find
out about your features to get best
practices to get tips and tricks and
general kind of a lot of advice and what
is the best way to succeed on Google
Play slotting these two in the are we
think both play console app and PlayBook
app would be useful all throughout your
kind of launch lifecycle so we just kind
of you know make sure make sure you try
them out and I think that's everything I
wanted to cover today
you